d remember I gave you two definitions
for real numbers two definitions there
you should have them there so you don't
need to rewrite them but I've got
written off bored so i'm going to
rewrite their most important bit right i
hope you can see there and maybe you
don't have it there you should write
this down the first definition the key
part was that any real number you can
write as a single decimal expansion do
you remember that yeah let me just think
about this idea for a moment because
probably when I gave you that definition
you're like oh so what okay seeing that
real numbers are single decimal
expansion helps you understand that even
though I've been drawing a whole bunch
of parallels between irrational others
like this and complex numbers like this
where n is just negative one there are
actually really really big differences
between them okay so if you've got a
calculator there can you get it out of
your bag for a second i want you to our
notice with me irrational numbers do
remember i described both of these kinds
of numbers to you as sort of like an oil
and water mixture okay we said it
rational numbers are famously antisocial
and they're not going to get together
with the rational numbers they're not
even at least together with each other
however the fact that they've refused to
mix together is actually mostly a
by-product of the fact that we write
them this way ok so just off on the side
here if you want jobs down and you
should
let's just think of an example okay now
if I gave you an irrational number like
this this is an irrational number okay
and I can't fix these two bits together
if i write them like this but if i write
each of the numbers as a decimal
expansion it sort of blows away the fact
it sort of lifts the veil and it shows
actually even though we write them as
two parts they're not so much you don't
have to write it that way let's just do
this separately to a seventh right to n
a7 if my memory is good I believe that's
two point one four to eight someone help
me out here some will go to bed 819 557
yeah and then every time believe yes
okay so there's a the recurrence yeah I
plate numbers on one um there's a
decimal expansion for two and a seventh
no big deal okay not in the same way you
can write the decimal expansion for root
n ok I've know it's your 10 is to help
me out it must be three points 3.16 give
me a give me of you 16 to 21
776 I kept done okay good now even
though the first number is not recurring
decimal and the second number is not if
it goes dr dot then i can have as many
decimal places as I like my calculator
stops but it keeps going right so as a
consequence I can just I can add these
two together just using my face value
okay um what is this number going to be
5.3 since election would go ahead oh
good so you can see the tool of decimal
expansions simply useful and it kinda
reveals actually that route and is not
as separate as it looks and that's why
you know a plus B brew damn you can have
written and root own routine with q and
whatever as many of them as you like but
you can still do the same thing to them
you can still combine them there's still
one number that's why they're still real
you can express them as a single decimal
expansion but we're not in real numbers
anymore wearing complex numbers and so I
hope you can see why these guys they
break apart this they don't fit into
this scheme ok despite the fact that
it's just a particular value of n
negative one right the square root of
negative one the imaginary unit is so
different to all the rest of the numbers
that it refuses to play all right it
won't mix with the arms no matter how
you write it it's always going to be a
separate peace okay so we need a better
definition for the complex numbers
okay I say there was a single decimal
expansion and I also gave you a special
name for that to remember to watch
that's with an S a scalar okay so
complex numbers refuse single decimal
expansions you need a pair of decimal
expansion and whenever you have a number
that really is actually two numbers
together you need both of them we don't
call that a scalar anymore does anyone
know what this is cause that's what
Aviva we call it a vector will come back
to this vector ID later on okay all
right so you can see number one we have
expanded out our first definition from
real numbers too complex what was the
second definition you remember what it
was very good any value that if you take
a line point on a line right I can say
well any real number you like even some
of the wee ones let me just point out um
you know how I gave you those five five
six equations that gave you the
different kinds of knowledge and
families of numbers even when you
include the complex numbers all those
numbers you came up with our what we
call I can't remember if I mention is
did I say this before no cool okay we
call them algebraic numbers on
surprising because you use algebra to
build the numbers okay there are some
numbers though that you can't build in
algebra they're not algebraic numbers
they have a super fancy name starts with
the tea does anyone know what they're
called even if you don't know what
they're called you know two of the
famous ones in fact I got one of them
are the boy pi is a famous nut but that
you can't deal with algebra right
there's no polynomial you can write
where pi is the solution if you just
stay with those the other favorites
number that you know
you can't do that really is 82.7 181 ah
ok these guys be called transcendental
numbers because they transcend algebra
ok now even the transcendental numbers
you can represent as a point on a light
bed there right he is between a two or
three and pines between three and four
it's in there somewhere ok but you can't
do it with the complex numbers you can't
place the complex numbers just as a
point on a line